I try to cover my tracks iced up but
they are not expired
Jacqueline Hill is speaking out on the
accusations she's selling expired
lipsticks
what the heck in a 14 minute long video
she shared to her nearly 6 million
subscribers on YouTube Wednesday the 28
year old beauty vlogger addressed the
situation head-on is the accusations
that my lipsticks are expired moldy or
hazardous in any way shape or form every
single ingredient in my lipstick is new
and it is FDA approved the girl came
with receipts literal receipts sharing
multiple screen shots from her
manufacturers with the date stamps that
seemingly indicate the line went into
mass production the same month as the
launch of the lipsticks a spokesperson
from Jacqueline Cosmetics also released
a statement to ET on Tuesday saying less
than half of 1% of the orders were
impacted by compromised product I want
to make this right for my customers this
is my first launch and it's very
embarrassing
Jacqueline launched the brand on may
30th and within hours the lipsticks
completely sold out this is my nude
lipstick collection we are launching
with 20 shades of all nude not long
after the launch fans and fellow Beauty
vloggers alleged that some of the lip
products they received contained plastic
balls and holes oh my god what these
black dots are are actually oxygen
bubbles and they are being lifted to the
service when my lipstick bullet is being
cooled off when it's going from a hot
temperature fresh out of the VAT and
it's gonna go into my actual component
and just be cooled down so that the
component cap can be put on top in that
process sometimes those oxygen bubbles
don't make it all the way through and
you'll see little itty bitty almost like
black like holes it's not actually like
black holes again it's not mold it is
oxygen and it is 100% safe and the
unknown fibers it's almost like like the
hair
and the plastic is inside of the
lipstick well Jacqueline addressed that
to my lab instead of using a standard
glob that they would use in the lab they
decided to use white cotton gloves
they're like fluffy white gloves because
they didn't want the standard gloves to
put any smears on this component to in
any way have any sort of prints on it
so they want to do a white fluffy glove
first when I heard this I thought but
wait how are a couple people wearing
white fluffy gob gloves gonna put this
many fluffy white little fuzzies all
over my products that doesn't make sense
right well then once I started seeing
videos I started seeing proof and then
my team actually did our own
investigation it actually made a lot
more sense in my mind and I'll tell you
guys exactly what that is on top of that
they were cleaning my vats which is the
big humongous bucket that has my batches
inside of it they were cleaning those
and vats with like this white fiber
almost towel going through it and that's
been happening about once a day they
said two sometimes twice a day depending
how quickly we're moving through batches
so those two things combined that is
what you were experiencing our little
white cotton fibers coming off of their
gloves and it is so beyond acceptable
now Jacqueline wants to make things
right revealing in the video she is no
longer working with the lab that helped
her launch the line and she is offering
a full refund and brand-new products to
those experiencing the issues all you
need to do is show them any proof a
video a photo whenever is and we will
take care of everything for you and make
it right
[Music]